welcome to may a month for games to be
released and puppies to frolic it's time
for new releases this week gearbox
grants us the first person shooter kinda
mobic kinda co-op campaign kinda wild
alien space game yeah all that it's got
a little bit of everything in there
every species fled to a star known as
solace after a disastrous event
destroyed most other planets and stars
in the universe these species are
divided into different factions upon
their arrival and finally they unite to
cooperate with each other by sending out
the best fighters who are labeled battle
born to fight against viral sigh the
origin of the catastrophe don't give a
sh is about the story you say well let's
talk multiplayer then you got 25
playable characters upon release each
having different abilities from melee
deranged healing you're bound to have
different battles each and every time
players gain enough skill points to
level up they can select one of up to
three choices to level up their
character through the helix tree then
they go back into the fray and shoot it
up you were born to battle on the 3rd
popular 2009 title shadow complex comes
back to us in remastered fashion for ps4
this week you can return to being Jason
Fleming in the Olympic Mountains with
his lady friend Claire but Claire gets
into some trouble so you'll have to
maneuver a massive underground complex
man by numerous soldiers and take on the
progressive restoration which appears to
be ready to launch attacks across the
United States those jerks use stolen
high-tech devices to infiltrate the
complex and save the day this game was
well received by gamespot back in the
day so if you want to relive the
adventure or you're just playing it for
the first time this is a pretty good
option we get reg Gant from Japan to
North America this week on PS Vita this
game takes place in a fictional future
version of Tokyo that has been left in
ruins due to the invasion of space
aliens called yep you guessed it now
before the Earth's complete destruction
the game's primary character icha was
able to defeat one of these horrible
creatures with a mysterious power it was
called yagami however at the same time
the uncontrollable nature of the power
also accidentally destroys an entire
city leaving the characters of the game
to figure it out how to handle this
ability control your powers on third
anytime I have a reason to talk about
the super sexy stylized super hot I get
excited so here we go this slow motion
first-person shooter is coming out on
xbox one this week so you get a new
reason to grab a pool ball and throw it
at some des dome right before you smash
dudes face with a bottle and cut a
bullet in half with your samurai sword I
mean those things actually happen those
are real scenarios that I went through
when I played this game it could be you
you could be doing that cool stuff we be
that cool guy get this sick ass game
finally let's talk about pc mac games on
Steam Cathy rain telling a compelling
story of a strong-willed college girl
with a knack for detective work this is
set back into the 90s from Cathy's
investigating a local mystery the legacy
of her recently deceased grandfather
she's following a trail of clues and
questions emerge who was Joseph rain
what's he doing what's he thinking about
why was he in that wheelchair was it cuz
he was old I mean who knows what secrets
does he hold the truth is probably dark
and sinister but you'd have to play it
to find out that is on the fifth you can
get it on Steam so that's all the games
coming out this week but stay tuned
because there's some big titles coming
out in May remember that release dates
are based on retailer listings and
sometimes they change I'll see you guys
again next week